the world has over 290 trillion dollars
of debt and we're starting to see things
break as a result of the rising cost of
paying for it and some of the world's
poorest countries Ghana is now
considered to be in high risk of that
distress as Salvador still tops its
ranking of Emerging Market countries
that are vulnerable to a debt default
the shock from massive debt loads and
higher repayment costs likely won't be
limited to developing nations I'm going
to explain how we're seeing these debt
crises hit emerging economies why it's
happening and why it could start to
affect larger and even wealthy countries
let's get into it developing countries
like Ghana Pakistan and El Salvador are
all starting to experience major
problems as a result of debt they're
shutting down power grids that serve
Millions reducing Hospital services and
warning that school lunches for the poor
may be ended this is a result of the
massive debt they've built up over the
years and the rise in cost of interest
payments governments only have so much
money and when they use more of it to
pay for debt there's less available for
other things like Health Care energy and
education as the Federal Reserve has
raised interest rates to try to cool the
highest inflation in close to 40 years
the dollar is strengthened the dollar is
valued against other countries
currencies so when it rises other
countries currencies decrease in value
okay let me break this down if one US
dollar is worth 10 Dion dollars and I
borrowed 10 US dollars at 10 interest I
have 100 Dion dollars and I owe 10 Dion
dollars in interest now if the value of
the dollar strengthens to 20 Dion
dollars I now owe 200 Dion dollars and
20 Dion dollars in interest even though
I only got 100 Dion dollars to start it
may not take long for the higher cost of
debt to become a problem for larger
wealthier countries and we're already
seeing some worrisome signs for
individuals governments and businesses
households in Australia Canada Denmark
and the Netherlands are already spending
at least 10 percent of their entire
household income on debt repayments a
number that's expected to reach close to
15 soon in the U.S just the interest
payments on the nation's debt reached
475 billion dollars in fiscal year 2022.
interest payments could exceed the
entire 767 billion dollar defense budget
by 2025. according to Moody's Analytics
around the world Moody's projects the
default rates for companies in the 1.5
trillion dollar high-yield debt Market
will almost double next year all of that
would mean that globally people will
need to reduce what they spend
governments will have to rein in their
services and business costs will get
much higher there's the potential for a
pretty serious Global recession and a
lot of economic pain it's like the great
Nas told us on his latest album King's
disease 3. a nobody Recession Proof
invest in you that's what is best to do
that's all for now I'll see you next
time
[Music]